[Music]
I'm James I'm 17 and I'm pretty sure I'm
a psychopath when I was nine but my
handy but deep fat fryer I wanted to
make myself feel something school was
beneath me but it was a good place for
observation and selection bad a plan I
was gonna kill someone
Hey seen you skating pretty [ __ ] [ __ ]
off with my mind stop thinking of you I
kind of think I could fall in love with
him I thought she could be interesting
to kill so I pretended to fall in love
with her this is nice what I thought
probably he was gay he doesn't correct
let's leave the [ __ ] town I'm going
with you come with me or not you in I
didn't know where we were going and when
I was gonna kill her
I punch my dad in the face and stole his
car and that felt like a good place to
start anything honestly
and the extra photos they don't say it
right Marvin can make a banana split to
me you [ __ ] seem that Alyssa had some
issues with James being with a missense
started to make me feel things have you
ever in a [ __ ] before all the time you
don't register the important moments
doesn't happen let me see that they more
important than we were back so Botox a
bells take your top off do you think is
gonna explode it's not a film I might be
able to fix it because neither here sure
I can you can still fix it why is no one
stopping probably because you've got
this hits out there are stuff some
weirdos accept / weirdos but you want to
lift come on I am gonna be so [ __ ] off
if we get murdered
[Music]